Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie aujourd'hui on s'retrouve sur Yandere Simulator !
Ca fait environ 600 années qu'on a pas fait un vidéo sur ce jeu !
Elle nous a manqué, on lui a manqué (ça j'suis pas sûr)
Aujourd'hui messieurs dames, nouveauté extraordinaire
un nouvelle arme. Vous savez bien que les armes sont sur la droite
quand on arrive a l'école hein !
Y'avait donc un couteau, un ciseau, un katana, un cuteur, un tournevis...
Et maintenant il y a... Ah c'est pas ici !
Et maintenant il y a un sceau !
Oui ça pu la merde ! (rire)
Mais nan c'est excellent, excellent, on va pouvoir faire des choses formidables avec ce seau
parce que : quoi de plus discret comme arme qu'un sceau !
On va le prendre, on va le remplir avec de l'eau !
On va redescendre voir tous nos p'tits copains, là qui sont en train de parler au milieu des cerisiers en fleurs hein !
ET ON VA LES BRÛLER !
c'est faux...
Aaaattention technique de fourbe nu-mé-ro 1 !
Si vous en avez marre d'une copine à vous
Elles sont toutes la en train de se parler "Ouais t'as vu la meuf, la nouvelle elle est bizarre blablabla"
AH OUAIS ?
Et bah tiens ! J'ai pas fais exprès putain merde !
Ah d'jà y'en a qu'une qui prend (rire sadique) c'est toujours la même !
Oh sérieusement ? Fais plus attention
Oooooh (sifflement) déjà tu baisses d'un ton.
On l'a suit et la ce qu'on va faire ça va être vraiment génial.
On va pas la tuer. On va pas la tuer. Bon on va la tuer !
Elle se dirige vers les douches, "mais pour quoi faire...?" me direz-vous
Elle va essayer de se sécher à l'aide d'un sèche cheveux peut être...?
Déjà on la voit à poil ! C'est toujours très correct parce que... putain elle a des boobs totalement énormes cette femme
Et la qu'est ce qu'on va faire ? Bah les photos !
On va se régaler !
Bon sa en vrai j'vais pas vous mentir, ça sert a rien, c'est juste pour notre plaisir (rire)
HOP LA ! Toujours plus de boules !
On va la prendre en photos, de devant ! HOP LA ! Ce qui est bien c'est qu'elle s'en bat les steacks !
Vraiment la meuf ! Aucune pudeur !
On peut la prendre en photos vu du dessus
Sa ce sera la miniature. HOP LA !
Ni vu, ni connu
Y'a du sang sur nous on va abandonner l'arme ici. Voilaaa juste a côter d'elle, elle s'est suicidée hein.
Elle s'est bien suicidée en s'mettant un coup comme ça (démonstration) on a déjà vu des gens faire ça
Des samuraïs qui préféraient s'ouvrir le ventre plutôt de perdre leur honneur. Hein ?
Putain merde du coup il faut qu'on se douche putain
On se met nue !
On se douche vite fait, bien fait ! Ok on s'est douché et là il nous faudrait un... un uniforme nouveau !
On va lui voler le sien ! J'peux pas ?
Ecoutez, j'ai une autre idée, on va prendre sa putain de dépouille
Et on va montrer aux autres ce qui va leur arriver si ils touchent à notre Senpai
"Oh mon dieu j'étais en train de me doucher et d'un coup j'ai vu euuuh cette femme mourrir !"
"Oui je sais c'est terrible !"
"Et elle ma mis nue avant de mourrir, j'ai pas compris pourquoi eeeet.."
Bon notre alibi est à chier eeeeuh prison !
Aller, fuuu ! Voilà tout a foiré ! OK OK OK !
Maintenant la version HARDCOOOORE
UN PUTAIN DE BIDON D'ESSEEEENCE
QU'ON VA VERSER DANS LE SCEAAAAU
ENSUITE ON PREND LE SCEAAAAU
MERRRRDE J'AI OUBLIE IL NOUS MANQUE UN TRUC (rire)
Et oui, les amis il nous faut avant eeeuh de pouvoir faire ça.. Des allumettes ! Pour foutre le feu a l'essence ! heein
On peut commander à ce mec mystérieux qui a une putain tête de pervers
des choses. Dont une boite d'allumettes !
Et ouais ! Mais pour cela il faut lui envoyer 5 photos de culottes ! Tous à vos appareils..
(musique Pedo Bear) Aaaah ouais là culotte là, y a d'la culotte là ! Oui y a d'la culotte là, la culotte fraiche (sent)
(jouissance) oh bien blanche gnéééé (rejouissance)
OK, après s'être bavé dessus à fond, on va maintenant pouvoir demander une faveur a cet immense pervers..
HOP ! une boite d'allumette c'est parti
Par contre je la reçois ou je la reçois par euuuh par Collisimo, par Chronoposte ouuuu
Où il les envoie les allumettes putain ? Où sont les allumettes ?
OH, OH, OH, qu'est ce que c'est que ça ? C'est des putain d'allumettes mon gars
Et ouais !
LE RETOUR DE LA VIOLEEEENCE
(parle vite) JE TRANSPORTE UN SCEAU D'ESSENCE MAIS PERSONNE NE S'POSERA DE QUESTIONS ET HOOOOOP LAAAA
Attends c'était de l'essence ou du sang ? C'est du sang ?
C'était... tin'... J'suis victime d'un complot là !
Nan mais je sais que je suis chelou mais là.. vraiment c'est la vérité
Y'avait de l'essence dans l'sceau quand on l'a poser t'haleur ?!
Qui a mit du sang dans ce sceau ? Mec... (rire) Y a une autre Yandere qui a voulu me piégé là
Ca, ça part en couilles, moi, j'arrête, après elle va débarquer ici elle va vouloir nous buter ! (l'autre Lucas) " gnééééé" on arrête tout...
C'est reparti pour prendre des culs en photos
(jouissance)
Nan eh pardon ! eeeeh excusez-moi
Ok, ok, ok... on se calme on a de quoi demander les allu....
2 !? Mais j'en ai envoyé 5 ! Ah le mec il me douille en plus d'être un gros pervers
Okkk on a les allumemettes !
Ok on a l'essence. Pardon. OK ON A L'ESSEEEEENCE
Eeeeeeh
HOP PARDOOOON ! Je transportais de l'essence j'sais pas pourquoi mais en tout cas j'suis pas coupable
Quoi ça sent quoi ça sent l'essence ? OUAIS c'est ça petite fdp.
ET MAINT'NANT
Oh merde elle s'enfuie
VIENT LA ! Elle est partie par où ? ok on la voit, on la prend en filature on la prend en filature, on va brûler on va la brûler
BRUUUUUUUUULE
HEEEEIN
BRÛLE ! MAIS NAN, NAN PAS.. NAN FAUT PAS QU'ELLE RENTRE DANS LE BAIN
Nan j'ai toujours l'temps j'ai toujours l'temps j'ai toujours l'temps
GNEEEEE
WOUH, OH ! OH EN CRIANT Y'A UN TRUC QUI EST TOMBER, en plus elle brûle ooooh
C'EST SATAN IL EST LA, IL EST AVEC NOUUUUS
Alors elle brûle dans d'l'eau !
C'est adorable ! (rire)
Mais elle est un peu posée quand même quand elle brûle (rire). Elle s'inquiète pas trop
Heeein elle a sa p'tite carte vitale son p'tit mé...
BRUUUUUULE (renifle)
Nan mais c'est sérieux là. Nan mais eh eh eh d'jà j'tiens à dire parce que je suis physicien à mis temps
Euuuuh l'essence ça brûle quand même dans l'eau hein ! C'est pas parce qu'y a de l'eau que ça éteint l'essence qui brûle hein !
Mais putain mais j'vais la buter mais laisse moi au moins t'faire eh aller une p'tite cicatrise, juste une allumette, une p'tite cicatrice
Une allumette c'est parti, allez !
Nan nan mais la j'accepte, j'accepte pas là c'qui s'passe c'est-à-dire qu'en fait tu vaaas.. Nan nan nan nan mais tu vas pas t'changer !
Mais tu crois qu'tu vas partir incognito ? Vas-y part !
Part ! Vas-y ! Tiens ! Tiiiens
(EXPLOSION)
Très bien ! J'ai compris on va la jouer plus discret et plus facile
Ici nous avons des poigts, on va les mettres dans ce sceau
Voilàààà
On les a maintenant les biceps
Alors maint'nant avec ce sceau on va aller sur l'toit
Vous savez comment sa va finir ?!
Tient tient ? Mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait au téléphone dit donc c'est pas bien ça ! HOP, je vais lâcher ce sceau ICI !
(rire diabolique)
Olaaaaaa eeh eeh lui fait pas bouffer to... (rire)
Elle lui mets des coups de genoux pour l'achever ou elle l'a sauve là ? (rire)
Elle s'allonge avec (voix aiguë) c'est hyper malsain.
Tu vas appeler la police ? Bah appelle la police, moi j'étais en train de discuter avec mon amie qui s'app... (bégaiement) euuh Stéphanie ! mon amie Stéphanie.
(coup de langue)
Olala j'transporte encore de l'essence et oooh nan
Oh chui tellement désolée
Pardon je transporte des allumettes et oh nan attention !
Merde...
Naan (rire) ça a encore foiré, j'en ai marre !
Tu vas brûler
Maint'nant on anticipe !
QUOI ?!
Là, on a l'temps. C'est parti !
AND BURN IT UP UP UP, BURN IT UP UP UP, I'M ON FIIREEEEE
Ah j'aurais au moins 10 j'aimes sur cette photo !
800 j'aime pour cette photo de Kokona qui brûle !
10 000 pour celle-ci parce qu'on voyait mieux les boobs !
Mh 100'000 pour euh... pfff cette pastèque sans boobs ! Ah nan c'est la cuvette des chiottes pardon
Je suis fakire, j'marche sur le corps de Kokona tout brûlé
Aaaaah
Aller vient avec nous, what's up les filles !
Voici c'qui vous arrivera si vous essayez de pécho Senpai
Que ce soit clair, voilà si vous avez faim vous pouvez tapper d'dans, c'est moi qui offre
Hop là j'prend l'sceau et j'ai..
Salut !
J'pense qu'on devrait faire un spectacle de magie toi et moi.
Voilà les gens c'est d'jà la fin de cette vidéo sur Yandere Simulator n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Et si vous voulez taper dans... Un p'tit molet cuit de Koko... J'sais plus comment elle s'appelle
On s'retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, on va terminer sur cette merveilleuse image du corps brûlé
Euuuuh c'est affreux
On va quand même garder une p'tite photo souvenir pour montrer qu'elle a voulu faire l'inverse de Mickaël Jackson
Elle est passée de blanc à noir
Pourquoi faut toujours qu'on finisse sur une blague de merde ?!
Allez, à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien ! Tchao tout l'monde, peace !